[Music]
on a recent episode of grit and growth
we explored the reality of raising
capital where none has been raised
before
with indian entrepreneur aditi
srivastava ceo and co-founder of pocket
aces entrepreneurship in india is
flourishing as today's guest sandeep
singh knows well
we have seen returning entrepreneurs the
next generation of talent is coming out
and starting their own companies so
whether it's a flip card whether it's a
snap deal whether it's a baijus all of
these companies are now throwing out
talent who are going on doing the next
thing
sandeep is the managing director of
mumbai-based nexus venture partners
he's an expert in venture capital in
india and has invaluable advice for
ambitious entrepreneurs
that individual when they're presenting
to me should get me as excited about the
problem as they are because that's what
they're going to do day in day out it's
not sales but it's motivation it's
getting that trust built in the other
person that hey i can make this happen
[Music]
i'm darius teeter and this is a master
class by grit and growth with stanford
graduate school of business the show
where africa and south asia's intrepid
entrepreneurs share their trials and
triumphs
today sandeep singh shares his knowledge
and experience in the world of venture
capital
we hear about what sets the indian
investment landscape apart how sandeep
decides which markets and ideas to
invest in and the single most important
characteristic he looks for in an
entrepreneur
[Music]
so without further ado over to you
sandeep so i went to stanford graduated
in 1987
worked for a startup in the bay area
that was funded by a vc so i got an
opportunity to actually see how
a vc funded startup works that company
was eventually acquired by
digital equipment corporation
so i actually saw the whole journey from
the time that the company was started to
the time it was exited it wasn't a great
exit for
the investors but uh it was an
interesting product that was built
subsequently i went to business school
and joined mckinsey
and while i was at mckinsey i came and
spent some time in india in 1997
and at that time there wasn't really any
real vc in india there weren't uh any
early stage investors
and so there wasn't really this capital
available at that time i i saw that gap
went back to the u.s
pretty much cleared my mind that i
wanted to do something in that space
ended up partnering with a fellow
mckinsey
partner and we started e-ventures
and that was uh
set up as a incubator and so from our
perspective uh it was
a play around two areas one was uh
looking at the internet economy and
seeing how we could bring global models
to the indian market and the second
focus area was looking at
global services indian companies that
could provide services to global clients
you're the managing director of nexus
venture partners can you tell me a
little bit about the firm and its
investment thesis
so the fund itself is based out of the
bay area so we have office in menlo park
and we have offices in india so we have
office in mumbai which is where i am
based and our office in bangalore
we
had two clear
areas of investment that we
felt were opportunities for in a
cross-border fund
the two areas that we identified
one was
cross-border technology
companies so these are companies that
are
starting in india but have a global
customer in mind
the second
area where we felt there was an
opportunity
was the domestic consumption play india
started seeing
significant growth on domestic
consumption in the 2003-2004 time frame
and we felt that that consumption would
move more and more towards digital
platforms
[Music]
what would you say has been the biggest
improvement
in the
startup landscape from an investment
capital race standpoint over this past
15 years this is just that deepening of
experience
more opportunity brought more talent
into the early stage funding space
absolutely uh the first thing was that
you had role models emerge
so we funded make my trip
in the original 2000 time frame
by 2006 2007 make my trip was a
reasonably large company they had a
business model that was was scaling
they had initially started with a
cross-border
play between
bringing indians back to india from the
u.s and other markets but by the time
2006 2007 they actually had a domestic
market play as well
so uh one was
somebody could look at what deep calvera
had built at make my trip and say i can
build something similar
maybe in a different area but i can
build something similar so they were
in some ways rule books that were
available for for founders to base their
businesses on
second uh capital
whether it was us a couple of other
funds got started at the same time
capital became available
and the third big shift that happened
was that
talent started coming to startups in the
earlier days
the best talent would go to large
companies
so you had the unilever
the mckenzies of the world getting the
best talent
but by 2006 2007 if you had a funded
startup
you could potentially get some of the
best talent from the business schools or
from the you know iits and so on the
other thing that has happened is we have
seen returning entrepreneurs the
companies that started in 2006 onwards
i think because they have only seen
growth from then on they've never seen a
downturn real a real downturn the next
generation of the
talent in those companies
is coming out and starting their own
companies so whether it's a flip card
whether it's a snap deal whether it's a
buy juice all of these companies are now
throwing out talent who are going on
doing the next thing
how is the indian investing environment
different from silicon valley today or
or is it
so the valley is still a lot more
vibrant in terms of the
idea exchange
in terms of uh talent availability
there's just a lot more depth
in terms of advisors people who have
sort of gone through the journey maybe
not even once they've gone twice or
thrice
and people have actually adapted you
know in the valley and in india it's
still early
from that perspective we are 30 40 years
behind
the other big sort of difference
in some ways is
india as a market
has only started evolving towards
a convenience-led approach
in more recent times what what does the
convenience let approach mean
india has been primarily a value-based
or a discount based market
so most of the companies that have
gotten created in india have used
discounting and price as a primary means
of competition now when you do that
one of the big drivers obviously is the
need for capital that is changing partly
i think kovit has had a role to play but
the other thing is
there is now more and more
shift towards uh the
consumer looking for
convenience and whether it is a zomato
or a swiggy on food delivery whether it
is
an academy on education
people are willing to pay
and they're willing to pay full price or
you know a good price let's say not full
price but a good price
for
the services that they're getting
and that makes the unit economics more
attractive it allows companies to scale
without taking up as much capital
and it allows founders to compete based
on product and experience and not just
based on price
that in my mind is is a big shift that's
happened
[Music]
let's go into some of the basics of
early stage investment
and i'm thinking here about some of the
inefficiencies in the preceding early
stage investment ecosystem
you know is there enough capital enough
high net worth individuals enough
angel investors
out there for entrepreneurs to find
there are enough executives from
large internet companies
there are enough high net worth
individuals family officers
that are
now doing angel investments in startups
so if you have a good idea and a good
growth story you should be able to find
an audience today yes uh and
interestingly this uh cohort of y
combinator
had uh
i think 40 of the companies are from
india that's the other shift that's
happening is
early stage capital is not just
available from indian angels
but indian companies are now being
looked at globally you have all the
accelerators from the globe now in
present in india tech stars is here y
combinators here angellist is here
the availability to raise capital from a
global pool is also increasing
okay i want to switch gears now and i
want to play a little game of investing
true or false
and so i'm going to ask you to say true
or false
and then to provide sort of a one or two
sentence explanation of why you answered
true or false so the first question is
angel or venture investors will want
their money back in five to seven years
true
the
rationale behind that is
we are working
with a finite amount of capital
and that capital has to be returned so
that it can be
re-utilized for the next stage of
innovation
and if a company hasn't scaled enough in
five to seven years and typically that
would mean that
you'll find it hard to scale from there
on
the expectation for
return on capital
is different for emerging market angel
investors than for silicon valley angel
investors
false
i i think angel investors globally are
looking for high returns
and uh
today indian investors are able to go on
to angel list
and invest in in valley-based companies
and vice versa
so everybody's looking for the best
company and the best return
so there's no artificial geographic
friction anymore in the system
capital will go where it wants to go
from a returns perspective yes everybody
they want equally high returns
next question
founders will see 20 ownership in each
investment round
mostly true there are companies where
because of
early market leadership the founder is
able to dictate terms
and reduce the dilution that they see in
in each subsequent round
in most cases
you will see a 20 dilution
between
producer rights and
ownership for the new investor coming in
but i understand from talking to a dt at
pocket aces that sometimes investors
will
have a de facto board seat but they
won't want to take on the statutory
liabilities of becoming an official
member of the board is that a common
practice
in india
particularly the global firms follow
that more than the
indian firms
okay so next true false question lead
investors will always ask for a board
seat
true
i have yet to see a
round getting done where the lead
investor did not ask for a good seat so
i would say it's true
okay next question
founders will not hold a majority stake
in their business post series a
false
you would have to
have been very very
diluted at the seed level
to have reached that position
so the only time when we see that is
when companies struggle to scale at the
seed level founders can overestimate
latent demand
and they end up struggling more to get
to a point where they are ready for
series a
that does sometimes lead to a higher
dilution at seed
if that happens it's a tough situation
for
everyone uh the founders and the angels
included because
typically a series a investor
does not like to be in a company
where post series a
the founders are below majority
the board will have the ability to
replace the ceo in later stages based on
that person's performance
true
the board does retain the right to
change the ceo
however
the founder
has a lot of operating control over the
business
so if they are doing
a terrific job the board will hardly
ever replace a founder
the idea is to have the founders scale
alongside the company
and to do that
you have to think forward along with the
founder and
either it is
helping them find
the right people to work with them to
cover for the areas where they may not
be experienced
or
the founder themselves
can you know pick up skills
[Music]
one of the things we learned from aditi
at pocket aces was that
having multiple institutions in a
funding round
meant that she looked to different
investors for different advice and
support in some of the deals that you've
done where you're side by side with
somebody else how do you work out
who's involved with what aspects of
advising
the founder is that all happening on at
the board level or where else is it
happening
so it starts with
the founder themselves right and this is
not just a firm issue it's actually the
board member
issue right so
one of the things that good firms do is
even though you have one board member
who's representing the firm on the
company's board
you're making yourself available as a
firm to the founder
so that's one thing that at nexus we
look at that a founder should be able to
talk to any one of us even though that
person is not on the board
as a board particularly on major issues
i think
it is very important to coordinate
and we do that both within the board we
also do it within the firm we have
conversations around our companies we
get feedback from other partners saying
hey this is have you thought about this
or have you thought about that sometimes
depending on how
you know you're thinking about the
problem
you'll say maybe you should go talk to
my colleague
on this particular issue because they've
dealt with it in a another company
and they may be able to give you
experience based advice rather than i
may give you theoretical advice
so i want to get a little bit into this
whole question of how do you get to know
an entrepreneur how do what
characteristics are you looking for when
somebody walks in the door what do you
need to know about them
number one is energy level you can tell
from a person in the way that they
interact with you what their energy
levels are and how will they
sustain their energy as they build out
the business define energy
it comes from passion
it comes from internal drive but it's
also about
how you are seeing the desire to build a
business and
good entrepreneurs just want to build
something big right they're not coming
in and saying i just want to solve a
problem there are many people that want
to solve problems but these are people
who are saying i want to solve a problem
at scale i want to solve a problem with
a good group of people i want to build
i want to have people around me that are
equally
passionate about building things that
energy that passion sort of is the
starting point
so they're not just a lone wolf
and they don't just have a compelling
problem they want to solve they have a
growth vision and they at least have
some people
who are with them that's correct
and so you're not looking at the numbers
at all at first or have you already done
a bunch of due diligence before they
even get in the front door
from a seed and series a perspective
it is less about numbers and it's more
about people
numbers really start coming into account
in series b and series c
but at a seed and series a
very few companies will have numbers
that you can depend on for making a
decision on a long-term basis
right i mean they'll put something in
front of you but you both know that it's
it's vapor
what we do look for is size of market
so for us it's very important that
you're planning to target a large market
and the reason why i say planning versus
saying you're targeting a large market
is because
there's a third part to this which is
focus
so you're passionate about solving a
problem you know that you're going after
a large market but you're doing it in a
very focused way
so sometimes what ends up happening is
the focus can make it appear that mark
that the market is small because you
know you have defined a niche you're
you're going after the
the top 100 000 customers that really
need audio books right and it may appear
like a small market but you can walk me
through and say okay if i get these
hundred thousand then i can get the next
million and then i get this next you
know five million so
so that's the third thing is focus and
many entrepreneurs struggle with that
that ability to
walk me through
why what you're doing right now
will allow you the right to get to the
next set of customers
how will you be able to take
the learnings from your 3 million in
revenue
and scale it to 10 20 50. right the this
is my growth horizon to get to this
point and then i'm going to go on to the
next growth horizon and the next one
right and an entrepreneur that's
thinking that way is also
very well aligned
from an investor perspective because
that's how investments work you start by
saying okay my first thing is i need to
get to a product market fit
the next thing is i need to get to a gtm
fit i need to be able to
have a have a go to market model which
is repeatable which is scalable the next
thing is i'm now going to be able to
protect my more whatever i've created as
a mode right so at each stage
you are thinking through what is the
nature
of problem you're solving in your
business
and a good entrepreneur is able to sort
of outline that
third is or the fourth thing is
the ability to motivate
that individual when they're presenting
to me should get me as excited about the
problem as they are because that's what
they're going to do day in day out once
they have the company and they're out in
the market they're going to be trying to
convince customers they're going to try
and convince the best talent and
employees they're going to be trying to
convince the best partners to work with
them right so
they have to get me convinced it's not
sales but it's motivation right it's
getting it's getting that trust built in
the other person that hey i can make
this happen
and the final thing is the ability to
listen and adapt what you need to be
able to and this is what we test in the
in the conversation is we'll throw them
a curveball we will ask a question
which would get you upset or which will
sort of say hey this this just can't
work right so
and we see how the person reacts do they
get upset
or are they sort of thinking why is this
guy telling me this what do i need to do
differently
you can tell that this person's
wheels are turning in their head and
they're thinking about the problem
they're thinking so that ability to
listen because the market is always
telling you something the competitors
are telling you something
so you want them to have
the passion and persua and the
persuasive power of an evangelist but
one who also listens
yes because if you don't listen
then you are stubborn
and the risk with being stubborn is you
can hit your head on the wall
and never be able to get across it so
another way i would think about this is
you want someone who's in love with the
problem they're trying to solve not with
their specific solution that is a good
way to put it
okay now i'm going to put you in the
other chair
i want you to go back to your days of
founding businesses and working in
startups
you're in a conversation with a
potential first-round angel or
c let's not say angel let's say seed or
series a investor
how should you be
uh assessing
this investor as a potential
partner
again the starting point is is this
investor passionate about this problem
maybe not as much as i am but at least
has enough passion
and is thinking about this not just from
a standpoint of okay i'll bet behind
sandeep and he'll make me money
so this is
a person who has thought about this
problem has a point of view on it
and
is therefore able to ask me intelligent
questions
so
they shouldn't be looking for someone
who just says
you convinced me here but let's do it
you actually ought to go past that
because i think a lot of entrepreneurs
would be so excited if that was the
initial response they would feel like
they just hit a home run i would at
least ask the person
what about what i said convinced you
in a nice way is there anything that i
could do that i should be doing
differently is there anything that you
know what is it that you think i should
you know do more of at least check that
this person is just not a uh so lazy
check writer but is actually going to be
a partner with you through the journey
because you want more than the check yes
because see any any startup is not a
straight line you are going to run into
problems which you hadn't anticipated at
the time of the fundraise
if there is an understanding as to why
that investment was made
you can always go back to that and say
this is what we were looking to do what
was wrong with our assumption and that
ability to do that
requires that there has to be some
common
set of assumptions between the
entrepreneur and the investor
so if you haven't had that conversation
at the start and the investor just gave
wrote you a check
then how do you have this conversation
later
i want to just ask you a little bit
about
the due diligence process we talked
about you know valuations don't really
mean much in these early stages
but is it a point of contention in the
negotiation
in today's world yes
valuations have crept up
uh there is an expectation
from all founders
that they should get
silicon valley based valuations not all
founders are targeting
very large markets
equally large markets or have the same
capabilities that some of the returning
founders in the valley or even in india
might bring
so what ends up happening is
uh they read stories in the press
that somebody raised 15 million dollars
in their c you know series a round
you know at a 35 free
money evaluation and
they think that hey you know if they can
do that ah maybe i'm not as good but
maybe i'll get at 25 rather than 35
and the real clearing price is 10 right
or eight
there is some level of expectation
management that needs to happen
in even early stage valuations
you've talked with so many founders and
evaluated so many companies that are
raising capital
what are the most common mistakes that
entrepreneurs make during those
early fundraising stages precede and
early stage funding
so one of the things i tell all my
founders is don't go to market
stating a
valuation expectation
you can share with the market what your
last round post money was you can share
with the market
how your company has grown from the last
round
but leave it at that
have the
market tell you what they think is a
fair valuation
second is
it is important for you to have
clarity on what are the risks that
you're going to
face
going forward in your business we see a
lot of situations where
entrepreneurs come
expecting everything to be hunky-dory
all the time
and it isn't the case
it means that they're not good listeners
they're not sort of seeing okay here's a
potential problem that i could run into
you should be able to
imagine what
that once you had the money in your bank
what would you do with it and what are
the risks that you would see and how you
would mitigate those risks we have
people that come to us for funding and
they haven't even understood what their
competitive landscape is
and that i think is just sloppiness
so those are the kind of issues
that you know a founder should be
should have a few conversations with
friendlies you know obviously talking to
your own
existing investors and using them as a
as a devil's advocate is very valuable
and
existing investors should do that they
should not try and
be cheerleaders for their founders
but in these situations
they should be very objective
and play the role of a external investor
it's a tricky thing to do because you
don't want to have that person get upset
at you for you saying something
you know you would uh but but it's
important that that person hear it from
you before they hear it from
an external investor
i'm just curious is there a question
that you wish i'd asked you what am i
missing here
how do you look at
various opportunities that come to you
right so today i can have an opportunity
that's coming
in a company that's you know building
the next marketplace it could be an
opportunity and then company that's
building the next education
uh portal there's a company that's
coming to me that has
the next you know content play now as a
investor
i have to make choices because
as a fund we are looking to invest
across
25 to 27 companies in a fund to create a
portfolio
so i'm looking at either the stage of
the company
i'm looking at the
industry in which they're playing
so i'm making a overall portfolio and so
sometimes i may have too much of a
weightage in a particular area in which
case i may not be able to invest in you
nothing wrong with the company that
you're running
sometimes you see three great companies
come to you
around the same time
how do you make a choice you're
basically saying i can only back one i
only have capacity to do one
how do i make that choice and that's
where
it's very important from a founder
perspective
to get to the right vc
and have a point of view as to
this fund
is more likely to invest in a content
play this fund or this partner
is more likely to back a marketplace
and try and get as much
information about
the individual not just about the firm
it's very important that you think
through and look at the partners look at
what the partners are doing look at what
their interests are what have they
spoken about
in the last you know six months about
their areas of interest people talk
about hey i'm looking at
investing in this area you need to sort
of stay on top of that as a founder
i think going in prepared
with an understanding of how the
investor
ecosystem looks like
can be very helpful
in a very running efficient fundraising
process
so how many deals do you look at a year
and of those how many do you actually
invest in and then i want to talk a
little bit about the ones you turned
away
normally we would do
seven to eight deals a year
these are series a investments
so we would probably do
an equal amount maybe more as seeds
so in the course of a
course of a year you'll probably end up
doing about 20 investments
or
18 investments out of which eight would
be series and eight to ten would be
would be seed investments
our series a investments would range
between say three to seven million
and our seed investments would typically
be anywhere between 250k to a million
sometimes we'll go slightly higher
we expect that in our seed investments
maybe a fifth of them or a quarter of
them would make it to a series a
and others won't so these are very
fundamental risks that we're taking
and uh to get to this number
we will probably see on average
500 to 600 companies a year
so you're saying no an awful lot yes and
what we do is we say no quickly
and we know we will get things wrong
for us a lot has to do with the founder
and the team
so sometimes you know you can look at a
plan and say you know the space doesn't
make any sense
but something about that plan says i
should at least talk to the person
so we will do a call with the person
and and sometimes you say you know
this may not be the right problem that
he's he or she is solving
but they are just a great just amazing
team
so let's go back and look at a seed
investment and see where they go
what i find fascinating about this is in
the seed round the personality of the
founder and the team are so important
when you're letting them down when
you're when you're in the room with them
and you're and you're going to say no in
a sense it must be hard for them to take
because you're saying no to them based
on their personality on who they are
and do they understand that and how do
they respond i mean i would love to hear
an example of
of an unsuccessful pitch and how you
handle it and how the founder accepted
that
normally
we will let the founder know that either
it is because of the space or it is
because we felt that there was something
in the way that they were presenting or
or the way they were taking the solution
forward
that we weren't comfortable with
it's not your role to be their
psychiatrist no but we will say hey
listen you know we think that you are
too focused on marketing and this needs
uh you to build a better product first
before we go and spend money on
marketing or it could be that
you need to build a team around you you
know
it's it's an interesting idea but we
just don't see a team that can execute
against it sometimes that person will
say
thank you for the feedback
goes and works on it for the next three
months and then comes back
others will just say you know
no more deal with this let's move on
so can you share a story of a time when
you didn't invest and then regretted it
later
so we did not put money into
hola hola is india's equivalent to uber
right so ola is the largest player in
the taxi space and
the reason why we didn't do it is
because
when he initially started
the regulatory frameworks did not allow
taxi hailing through an app
and so
there was a risk of either
direct reliability or potentially this
thing being shut down by the government
and so we didn't want to take that risk
we
did not
invest in freshworks at this point other
than zoho it's india's largest sort of
software sas company
because
our view was that they were at the point
that they came to it for investment they
were effectively a copy of zendesk
interestingly the initial growth that
happened was because the zendesk founder
wrote a rant
and complained about how freshdesk had
just totally copied zendesk
and how they were just trying to compete
on price
and any customer that you know was
looking for a helpdesk solution at the
time and felt zendesk was too expensive
went to freshdesk
so
infamy is as important as fame right you
take what you can get even if they're
copying something that is global
how will they differentiate and and
greece had a had a clear path of how
they would differentiate themselves
vis-a-vis zendesk and they've done that
and that brings us to the end of today's
masterclass i want to thank sandeep
singh for sharing his insights with us
today
from sandeep's perspective early stage
investment decisions are often based
less on the numbers and more on the
people involved
for entrepreneurs to attract strong
partners they need to demonstrate real
insight into the competitive landscape
of their market
and to build businesses that solve
problems at scale founders need to have
a strong internal drive
and for sandeep what he looks for an
entrepreneur is clear
number one is energy level that
individual when they're presenting to me
should get me as excited about the
problem
as they are
this has been a master class from grit
and growth with stanford graduate school
of business and i'm your host darius
teeter
if you want to find out more about how
stanford graduate school of business is
partnering with entrepreneurs throughout
africa and south asia
visit seed.stanford.edu
podcast
if you like this episode don't forget to
hit follow and share it with a friend
written growth is a podcast by stanford
seed from stanford graduate school of
business
lori fuller researched and developed
content for this episode with additional
research by jeff cricket
kendrick gladice is our production
coordinator and our executive producer
is tiffany steves
with writing and production from isabel
pillard and sound design and mixing by
alex bennett at lower street media
thanks for joining us we'll see you next
time
[Music]
you